to joy behar's point uh trump did not
bring in incivility incivility had been
here a long time trump had been in civil
for a very long time you know i used to
work for the guy i know how uncivil he's
always been uh the culture has been
shifting toward incivility and this me
me me me me narcissism for a very long
time and it's exacerbated constantly and
it just grows exponentially each year i
find uh this this case in particular
this guy seemed batshit crazy had a
grudge wanted to hurt dave chappelle in
front of everybody okay that's different
that's a little different than what will
smith did
but i also think what's going to end up
happening is comedy is probably going to
change which is the biggest tragedy of
all because comedians are the last
truth-tellers we have you can't tell a
joke without truth in it it's not funny
otherwise and i think comedians are
going to start to adjust their sets
to not offend and to make sure that
stuff like this doesn't happen
particularly if they don't have an
entourage like chappelle that's probably
and that's the biggest danger of all
right let's talk about it with
tony hinchcliffe yeah that's not that's
not we need we need those guys to stay
loose real quick you uh you get up on
stage every so often yeah you have your
events you speak let's say something
like this happens to you not to this
extent but some guy bum rushes you on
stage what is what's your response
but you have to re it's happened and
it's gonna happen that's not something
like bush is on stage talking with
another you know prime minister
president guys throws two shoes at the
guy you know so it's not moments of that
yeah so you have to know this is not a
new thing you know the guy who went
after you know
president uh you know had an infatuation
for michelle pfeiffer she what do you i
was doing it because i wanted to impress
michelle because you don't you don't
know people's motives this whole thing
we do with the event last couple days
right
here's what we don't know we don't know
the guy's real story
we don't know what lee is telling this
isaiah lee guy we don't know what he's
telling himself we don't know what's in
his brain and that's not the truth but
it's his truth right to him that's the
reality of what's going on you don't
know what these guys are telling
themselves but i don't think it's a new
thing i don't think it's been uh
it just started happening like a you
know two weeks ago it's like the tyson
thing like you mentioned it earlier
somebody went up to tyson with a gun and
what does he do he talks the guy down
and gives him a hug like like you say
man this happens all the time it's just
this gets national headlines yeah the
only difference is the only difference
is
if
if
they do something like that and hurt a
guy size of chapelle with his kind of a
notoriety
shit's going to change very quickly so
that's the one thing they have to
realize shows are going to change
format's going to change security is
going to change everything's going to
change so just think about having to
stand in line for four hours to get in
how annoying is it to go to a show
imagine waiting for four hours we had
president bush at one of our events what
was it three years ago four years ago
right so we've been working on you know
we invited him and we invited obama
obama doesn't do anything in august our
events are always in august
and boys said i'll make it so he came to
the event do you know we had to have a
hundred secret service agents we had to
have security where what do you call a
metal detectors everywhere we had to
invest that money and have it everywhere
to come in they had meetings with us
they had meetings with our crew they had
meetings with people that are on the
inside everybody had a yellow sticker
that you kind of knew
you're trained by secret service to know
that for the next four days while the
president's coming they were so fully
prepared for it right things are going
to escalate when things like this happen
i just don't think that's the last event
that we're going to hear about i think
it's going to you hit the nail on the
head with the 911 reference you said
that you know 9 11 happened september
boom couple months later in november tsa
okay so it's weird that the hollywood
bowl didn't have metal detectors i think
they would the hollywood bowl under you
know i mean but it will is my point now
god forbid dave chappelle's in the
hospital some stab wounds
boom the tsa reference becomes all too
real into the hollywood until we think
about it we used to just go into into
arenas and to theaters yeah walk right
in get your seat right now you're
getting covet-tested you're going
through metal detectors they're patting
you down
it takes unfortunately a freaking
tragedy a 911 esque horrible tragedy
dave chappelle god forbid getting
stabbed tragedy for
venues to be like dude that we're not
gonna take the risk right and that's
just what happened yeah i mean again i i
okay if you were to vote do you think
we're going to hear another story in the
next 30 60 90 days yeah oh no doubt no
doubt about it i agree i think it's
going to be 30 60 90 days and i think
uh if i'm the guy that's putting events
together this is an opportunity for me
to say hey dave let me tell you what our
format's gonna be for you to feel
protected okay so when i had kobe bryant
at our event
uh 5 000 people rushed the stage okay
you can see this on video and kobe
sitting right next to me like what the
hell is going on right
and right there i had security standing
in the front okay
we had were you you were at that event
okay i had security standing right out
the front and i had to get up and i
asked these guys everybody's gotta sit
or else i'm gonna ask colby to leave so
there was a that whole interaction with
us see if i have that at the opening or
no click on uh well the challenge is
it's going to take a minute to see it
anyways
i think the event holders have to be
more organized to provide a better level
of security for the talent coming in
because talent doesn't know your
audience talent wants to feel protected
it's the job of the event
hoster the host of the event to protect
the talent that's coming in so we have
people that come here all the time let
me tell you what we do did you see the
car parked outside okay what do we do
with that we want our talent to feel
safe that guy's a share of 16 years by
the way he's been you know if you see
who's what his background is somebody
tries to do something here we're
protected right guns blazing
everything's prepared right we want to
make our talent feel special that's
exactly what these guys got to do right
there 5 000 people rushed the stage
so so he's sitting right next to me and
all of a sudden boom everybody rushes
the stage he's like what the hell is
going on i got security at the front you
know the next thing you know things
change so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]